- You don't have to be
an asshole to succeed.
- This is true.
- [Female Voice] Ladies and gentlemen,
your attention please.
- What the fuck?
(alarms blaring)
- I thought we were out of
time, and I was just like--
- Yeah, me too!
(both laughing)
Should I carry on?
What was I gonna say after that?
Hi I'm Gina, I'm here with
Bobby from Netflix's "Queer Eye"
and here are his Netflix Nine.
Okay so my first question to you
is going to be about "Queer Eye."
- Okay.
- Which is your favorite
"Queer Eye" episode?
- People ask me that all the time
and I don't have a favorite baby.
We have a least favorite baby,
but we don't have a favorite baby.
- Can I tell you my favorite
episode with you?
- Yeah.
- Hold on, because I only
just recently watched it.
Thank you so much, thank you.
One with, I think it's Rob.
And he's a widower
- Oh, Rob and his sons.
- and the two sons.
- Yes, Rob Elrod.
He is such a sweet man.
- But you were just so gorgeous
in that episode and so nice.
- Aw!
- I know!
Maybe I'm just buttering you up
'cause I really want you
to be my best friend.
If you could swap homes
with any celebrity,
who would you choose?
- The queen.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, I mean who wouldn't wanna
live in the palace?
- Oh yeah, I guess so!
- Yeah, yeah, I guess.
- The best house out there.
- Don't you feel intimidated
by the amount of rooms?
How many rooms does it have
in the palace, like 600?
I made that up.
- Buckinham Pa--
- No no no, I made that up.
- Actually, Mandy Moore's house,
have you seen it recently?
- Yes, oh my God!
- Which, we have the same pool guy.
The guys that built hers
is building mine right now.
- Oh really?
- So I'm hoping that mine
just looks just even slightest
bit like Mandy Moore's.
- Her house's awesome and
she's the sweetest woman ever,
- She's so nice.
- But her house looks
beautiful, totally my style.
- And if you could decorate
any celebrity's home,
who would it be, or you
could have a celebrity
decorate your home, either/or.
- Probably wouldn't want
anyone to touch mine.
- Okay that is absolutely fair.
(both laughing)
- I don't know, I never know
who any celebrities are.
- Oh.
- I always get the same question,
"What celebrity do you wanna make over?"
And I'm like, "Oh, ya know,"
I try to spin it with,
"Ya know, we don't
really make people over,
"we try to make them better."
And she's like, "All right,
"well who do you wanna make better?"
And then I was like, "I don't know.
"I don't know who anybody is."
And she's like, "What
about Cole blah blah blah?"
Cole somebody, I don't know,
he was some Disney star.
- Oh, Cole Sprouse?
Riverdale?
- Yes!
She's like, "What about Cole Sprouse?"
And I'm like, "I don't know who that is."
She's like, "He's standing
right next to you."
(Gina laughs loudly)
Hi! (laughing)
- That is so embarrassing!
"Hi, I'm Bobby, nice to meet you."
- Yeah, I don't know who that is!
- So how long, when
you're making over homes,
you're doing home projects,
how long does it actually take
for you to do that
for each?
- I get the home on Tuesday
afternoon and I have it
back by Friday morning.
- I just don't underst-- okay.
- Magic.
- But you don't even plan or anything?
- Oh no there's planning.
- Okay.
- And the thing is I go out
a few weeks before the other boys.
- Oh, I see.
- And I get a warehouse and
I just buy tons of stuff,
and I kinda make my own store.
- When I spoke with Tan, few months ago,
he said his biggest
inspiration was Michelle Obama.
And I was watching--
- He told me that I was
his biggest inspiration.
- It was a lie, I'm so sorry (laughs).
He told me Michelle Obama, I--
- Well mine's Barack Obama!
- Yeah, well that's what
I was gonna ask you.
- It actually is.
- Yeah, I saw an interview that said
that yours was Barack Obama,
and I wanted to ask if that's true.
- Yes
- Why Barack?
- Why?
- I mean, I love you, Barack, but I--
Just because of everything
he represents, the hope,
the kindness, the
generosity, the intelligence,
I mean, everything.
Karamo met him and he borrowed
one of my suits to wear
when he went to meet him,
and Barack gave him a hug,
and so I'm like (sniffing),
Barack's touched my suit!
The other day, I was having
lunch with Oprah, no big deal.
(both laughing)
And we were at the first
annual Empowerment Awards
and she was getting an award.
Everything that was
coming out of her mouth,
I'm just like sitting at
the table trying not to cry
at a luncheon in Hollywood.
- Yeah.
- If she ran for president, she would win,
but I can also understand why
she doesn't want to because--
- No, I get it too.
- She does so much good in the world
and does what she wants to do.
And when you're president,
your hands are tied in so many ways.
- Yeah.
- I think she does more for the world
as just Oprah than President Oprah.
- I actually just wanted to
say that earlier you said
that you don't know many celebrities,
and then you've just said that
you had brunch with Oprah.
So, ya know what, fair, I love that.
(both laughing)
That's how I wanna be, I love that a lot.
So, what's something about British culture
that you particularly like?
- How direct people are.
- Oh really, you think we're direct here?
- Well I mean, some people say
direct, some people say rude,
some people say tomato,
some people say tomato.
- Okay. (laughs)
- But that's one thing we
can always count on with Tan,
he'll flat out tell you the truth.
We're like, "Tan is this cute?
"No."
- Okay, okay, that's true.
And what's something about British culture
that you don't understand?
- The humor.
- Really?
- I don't understand why it's funny.
(both laughing)
- "Queer Eye" is a groundbreaking show,
in terms of LGBTQ representation.
Is being a part of that
representation important to you?
- Absolutely.
- Why do you think it matters?
- I think it matters because
growing up as the little
gay boy in Missouri,
I didn't have that representation.
I didn't have people to
show me that A, it was okay,
B, that I would be okay,
and that I could make it,
that I'd be able to get out of there
and be able to live a normal life,
just like any other person.
So I think that's why it's important
to have that representation,
for the younger generation
to be able to see that you're okay.
- Absolutely
- And you'll be okay.
- Okay so what are three
things you can't live without?
- Sad, but my phone because
it runs my world, coffee,
and ...
- That's very American.
- My husband.
- Aw!
All right, we get it.
Love it real
- I was like,
"I'm either gonna say
bacon or my husband."
(both laughing)
- Hard to say, depends what day.
- Either way, they're yummy.
- Okay so, I don't wanna
put you on the spot,
but I spoke to one of your
other members of "Queer Eye,"
and when I asked about the
sixth member of "Queer Eye,"
he said he would choose me.
I'm not saying that you should choose me
to be the sixth member of "Queer Eye,"
but if you were to choose
anybody to be the sixth member.
- It would be you.
- Thanks, that's all I wanted to hear.
- We're done.
- Yeah, we're done, do you
want me to ask some more?
- Yeah, I want some more.
- Well, ya know, it's only nine
questions, isn't it, babes?
(both laughing)
Netflix nine hours of
me and you just talking.
- Yeah, Netflix Nine ...
Hours.
(both laughing)
( peaceful guitar music)